just four days away from the election
day both candidates are taking their
campaigns to the midwest today
joe biden is making his closing
arguments at driving events
where some people get out of their cars
and surround the stage
by contrast president trump is holding
pac rallies where many of his supporters
are shoulder to shoulder and do not wear
masks
the new campaign swings come after the
worst day on record for new coronavirus
cases in this country
the u.s reported more than 88 thousand
cases shattering
the previous daily high that's the
backdrop for ed o'keefe who is
following the campaign ed what's the
state of the race as we head into the
final weekend
well good morning anthony we're here in
new york outside an early voting site
that stretches two blocks they just
opened the door
scenes like this repeating themselves
all across the country today
and the candidates making last-minute
outreach to those who may have yet to
make up their mind
today they spend time in the same
midwestern battleground states
on thursday they spent time in a much
warmer place
florida i'm thrilled to be here
in my our home state
florida on thursday the president and
joe biden rallied their supporters in
tampa florida hello tampa
temp is part of the critical central
florida corridor that often decides
statewide elections the rallies were
starkly different in messages
and visuals at biden's
smaller drive-through rally he slammed
the president for holding yet another
one of his bigger rallies earlier in the
day
with few masks and no social distancing
donald trump just had a super spreader
event here
again they're spending more
more than just coronavirus he's
spreading division
and discord you know the bottom line
though you're gonna get better you're
gonna get better
if i can get better anybody can get
better not only did the president again
downplay the virus which is surging
across the country
he also encouraged measures not being
followed at his own rallies
if you get close wear a mask always
controversial it's not controversial to
me
you get close you were a mess social
distance mr trump also boasted about the
record economic growth in the third
quarter
this is the biggest event in business in
50 years nobody's ever seen a number
like this
under president trump his campaign
quickly unveiled a new ad to tout the
numbers
look at that the economy growing at a
record 33.1
but more than 12 million americans are
still without a job and the economy is
still not back to its pre-pandemic highs
economists warn its weakening again as
coronavirus cases climb
i'm not going to shut down the economy
i'm not going to shut down the country
i'm going to shut down the virus but
biden had to cut his tampa event short
god bless you all because of the rain
while the president was forced to
postpone a rally in fayetteville north
carolina due to high winds and rain left
over from tropical storm zeta
earlier in the day some supporters at
his tampa rally had to be escorted out
amid hot humid temperatures
and yet another example of how the
pandemic is upending
everything but especially in this case
elections iowa
where biden is headed today is one of
those states that has had to consolidate
hundreds of polling sites into a
smaller number of locations out of
concern with the pandemic but
elections officials there and across the
country are hoping that because
so many people continue to vote early
that the lines on election day at least
won't be that bad i tell you guys you'd
think we were covering a tropical storm
in manhattan this morning
but it is inspiring that sounds cliche
but it's true inspiring to see
so many people in line this morning
stretches two blocks
into the middle of manhattan these
people have been waiting more than an
hour
to vote and again we're seeing this all
over the country
no there is a feeling that over that
that when you get in those lines when
you get that ballot and you fill it out
there is a feeling
uh and it's worth it so people should
stick with it and thank you very much we
appreciate it